the last major hurricane to make
landfall in the Tampa Bay area was in
1921 that's almost a century ago Jeff
Glor is in st. Pete Beach Florida just
outside the mouth of Tampa Bay it is
expected to take a direct hit from the
storm overnight Jeff good morning Nora
good morning to you we are right next to
the Gulf of Mexico on one of the barrier
islands just west of Tampa the last time
a major hurricane made a direct hit on
this area the population was about a
hundred and thirty-five thousand now
it's closer to three million twenty
times as many people that is still less
than the population of South Florida
which is getting pounded by hurricane
armor this morning the biggest concern
right now is for the Florida Keys the
eyewall getting very close to that
low-lying chain of islands thousands of
people have been evacuated but others
have stayed behind Elaine Quijano is
watching the situation there she is in
Florida City the last town on the
mainland before you get to the keys lane
good morning good morning to you Jeff
again the story here out of Florida City
at this hour continues to be the wind
and the rain I have to tell you just in
the last 30 minutes or so the winds have
started to really pick up where it is
difficult at times to stand because
these are hurricane-force gusts that we
are feeling very easy to get toppled
over frankly with some of these gusts
have been really intense I want to just
give you a little bit of a look around
here this is the scene palm fronds down
the kind of thing that will likely be
seeing all throughout this particular
area you mentioned where we are right
now let's take a look at the second
camera overseas highway is just over my
shoulder there in the distance that is
also Route one the only way in and out
of the Florida Keys and
at the end of that road lies Key West
after 42 bridges the city of Key West
now hunkered down there was a mandatory
evacuation for the keys but in Key West
and other communities many people
decided not to leave the powerful winds
and soaking rains promised by Hurricane
Emma have arrived in South Florida from
Key Largo all the way down to Key West
power lines and transformers exploded
under the stress of the storm and downed
trees littered neighborhoods mandatory
evacuations were issued for the keys
days ago but some people chose to ride
out the storm
Monroe County Sheriff Rick Ramsey took
refuge in his shelter in Marathon in the
heart of the keys alongside other words
lieu idiots
we have no power anywhere in the county
why didn't you leave they said I didn't
think it'd be that bad but most people I
think come to conclusion that they
should have left video shared on social
media overnight appears to show some of
those who didn't leave the keys despite
the repeated warnings for the governor
rick Scott every Floridian should take
this seriously and be aggressive to
protect their family possessions can't
be replaced your life your family cannot
be replaced
and back here in Florida City in the
homestead area where again the winds
have really begun to pick up residents
that I've spoken with here both in the
homestead area and also folks who
evacuated the keys say this storm to
them feels different there are people
that I've spoken with who are here where
we're staying who said they haven't
evacuated in the past but because of
what they were seeing and because of the
warnings that were out there they felt
this particular hurricane was something
that could not be taking a chance on
they felt they had to get out and they
are worried one man from marathon told
me that he is all but certain the first
floor of his home is going to be gone
when he returns hopefully later this
week Gail yeah that's a whole nother
part of the story thank you very much he
Lane